Katrina: 得了我会觉得自己很不爽
Katrina: Fine, but I feel really uncomfortable.
Katrina: 就是干什么都都会留心眼
Katrina: I mean, I have to be cautious about everything.
Katrina: 就但是我还是行为上还是就这样
Katrina: But I still act the same way anyway.
Katrina: 玩玩啊
Katrina: Just playing around.
Katrina:  清华那也是保研认识就是
Katrina: I met someone at Tsinghua for a guaranteed postgraduate spot.
Katrina: 就玩过两次
Katrina: We hung out twice.
Katrina: 不知道人家啥意思
Katrina: I don't know what they meant.
Shure: 什么时候开始
Shure: When did it start?
Katrina: 就是啊
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Katrina: 主要是我昨天那手工那个教学视频
Katrina: Mainly, my craft tutorial video from yesterday...
Katrina: 不知道那个二维码呢
Katrina: I don't know where that QR code went.
其他人：去找商家
Others: Go find the vendor.
Katrina: 商家
Katrina: The vendor?
Shure: 这点谁是哪个商家理你
Shure: At this hour, which vendor will bother with you?
Shure: 真当商家不是人呐
Shure: Do you think vendors aren't human?
其他人：这点客户应该没下吧可能吧
Others: The customer probably didn't download it, maybe.
Katrina: 进去坐吧对
Katrina: Let's go sit inside, yeah.
Katrina: 哎搞瓶饮料喝喝
Katrina: Hey, let's get a drink.
Katrina: 哎想去喝那个real的那个桃子味
Katrina: I want to try that peach-flavored Real drink.
Katrina: 现在经过朗姆的调教现在已经轻松
Katrina: Now, thanks to some training with rum, I'm more relaxed.
Jake:呵呵呵多多少迪普啊这
Jake: Haha, how much of a deep drinker are you?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别学我说话了
Katrina: Haha, stop mimicking me.
Katrina: 学我说话好贱呐耶耶耶
Katrina: Mimicking me sounds so annoying. Yay, yay, yay.
Jake:确实来吃吃吃吃吃吃吃吗
Jake: Sure, let's eat, eat, eat, eat, eat!
Katrina: 等一下吃
Katrina: Wait a moment, let's eat later.
Katrina: 我要去拿瓶饮料喝
Katrina: I want to get a drink first.
其他人:好这个蛋糕吗
Others: Okay, how about this cake?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:这今晚得吃
Jake: We need to finish it tonight.
Jake:明天还得再做一遍
Jake: We'll have to make another one tomorrow.
Jake:因为这这过不了夜
Jake: Because it won't last overnight.
其他人:过不了夜
Others: It won't last overnight?
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 全部都得吃完
Katrina: We have to finish it all.
Shure: 哦对你知道吗
Shure: Oh, by the way, you know...
Shure: 这个这个蛋出席都好吃
Shure: This, this egg is really tasty.
Shure: 你可以你可以直接拿手夹一块
Shure: You can just grab a piece with your hand.
Jake:我再拿一个
Jake: I'll grab another one.
Katrina: 哦买噶
Katrina: Oh my god
其他人:好吃有一股牛排的香味
Others: Tastes good, it has a steak flavor
Jake:我回新加坡去验证一下
Jake: I'll go back to Singapore to verify it
Jake:称重我拿的时候没称你不知道吧
Jake: You didn't know I weighed it when I took it, did you?
Shure: 实在楼上吗
Shure: Is it upstairs?
Katrina: 嗯你要吗
Katrina: Yeah, do you want it?
Katrina: 还有青提跟草莓味
Katrina: There's also green grape and strawberry flavor
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:拆一个菠萝的
Jake: Open one of the pineapple ones
Jake:我靠这怎么吃啊
Jake: Damn, how do you eat this?
Jake:我我那
Jake: I'll, I'll...
Jake:那得拆一下
Jake: We need to open it up
Katrina: 还写什么呀
Katrina: What else should I write?
其他人:直接吃吧
Others: Just eat it
Katrina: 刚不都跟你那个了吗
Katrina: Didn't I just do that with you?
Jake:你给我分一下
Jake: Share it with me
Katrina: 你已经毕业了
Katrina: You're already graduated
Jake:你怎么也吃不了了
Jake: You can't eat it either
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:来分分一下
Jake: Come on, share it
其他人:吃不下了
Others: Can't eat anymore
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:你这不行啊
Jake: You can't handle this
其他人:你为了减肥
Others: You're on a diet
其他人: 我要不减肥真瘦不下
Others: If I don't diet, I can't lose weight
其他人:让我吃一点
Others: Let me have a bit
其他人:你怎么吃增增重
Others: How do you eat to gain weight?
Katrina: 哦哦好
Katrina: Oh, okay
Jake:你你你怎么瘦的呢
Jake: How did you lose weight?
其他人:我怎么瘦的
Others: How did I lose weight?
其他人:我不知道啊
Others: I don't know
其他人:我每天晚上吃东西
Others: I eat every night
Katrina: 是什么
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 蛋挞皮吗
Katrina: Egg tart crust?
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn
其他人:要不你吃这一块
Others: Why don't you eat this piece?
Jake:为啥有什么差别
Jake: Why? What's the difference?
其他人:那这个分我一半啊
Others: Then give me half of this one
其他人:我想尝尝那个菠萝
Others: I want to taste that pineapple
其他人:这菠萝
Others: This pineapple
其他人: 太甜了
Other: Too sweet.
Jake:你这开会怎么没耳机
Jake: Why don't you have headphones for the meeting?
其他人:不开了
Other: Not using them.
Katrina: 面还有鸡肉卷
Katrina: There's noodles and chicken wrap.
Jake:确实很肉松
Jake: It's really fluffy.
Jake:对你不吃
Jake: You’re not eating it?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 还有杯咖啡谁点的没喝
Shure: There's also a cup of coffee that no one drank.
Katrina: 这咖啡还牛奶
Katrina: Is this coffee with milk?
Jake:谴责强势谴责
Jake: Strong condemnation.
Shure: 一个浪费咖啡一个浪费牛奶
Shure: One person wastes coffee, another wastes milk.
Katrina: 不会有人点咖啡的牛奶吧
Katrina: No one would order milk with coffee, right?
其他人:你见过这个吗
Other: Have you seen this?
Shure: 这是谁的谁点的
Shure: Whose is this? Who ordered it?
其他人：那还有一个卷还有俩汉堡
Other: There's still a wrap and two burgers.
Katrina: 哦买噶点这么多
Katrina: Oh my, ordered so much.
Katrina: 嗯牛奶吗
Katrina: Hmm, is this milk?
Shure: 嗯牛奶
Shure: Yeah, it's milk.
Katrina: 我刚开
Katrina: I just opened it.
Katrina: 今天晚上嘎嘎上厕所两杯灌下去
Katrina: Tonight I'll be running to the bathroom after drinking two cups.
Katrina: 早上你们楼下听到我咚咚咚哈哈哈
Katrina: In the morning, you’ll hear me stomping around downstairs, haha.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No way.
Katrina: 没事你搜点那PNA干活
Katrina: It's okay, just search PNA to get some work done.
其他人：我是双的
Other: I have double eyelids.
其他人：你也是双的
Other: You have double eyelids too.
Katrina: 不要按呀
Katrina: Don't press.
Katrina: 我也是双眼皮
Katrina: I have double eyelids too.
Katrina: 我是内双
Katrina: I have inner double eyelids.
其他人：你什么双啊
Other: What kind of double eyelids do you have?
其他人：你是全自动双
Other: You have automatic double eyelids.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 手动双
Tasha: Manual double eyelids.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Alice:你要不贴了双眼皮贴吧
Alice: Why don’t you use double eyelid tape?
其他人:贴双眼皮贴眼睛会大
Other: Using double eyelid tape makes your eyes look bigger.
其他人:有双眼皮贴吗
Other: Do you have double eyelid tape?
Katrina: 有啊你们应该有
Katrina: Yeah, you guys should have some.
Katrina: 快搜一下q n a chat gpt搞一下
Katrina: Quickly search QNA Chat GPT, get it done.
Alice:我没有
Alice: I don't have it.
Jake:来搜搜搜搜搜搜
Jake: Come on, search, search, search, search.
Shure: 你要2楼弹个QNA吧
Shure: You wanna do a QNA on the second floor?
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 速度
Katrina: Hurry up.
Jake:二楼什么投屏啊
Jake: What's the second floor projecting?
Jake:行那你抱着电脑去吧
Jake: Okay, then take the computer with you.
Jake:你你用什么东西搜
Jake: What are you using to search?
Jake:你用GP行
Jake: Are you using GP?
Katrina: 赞
Katrina: Nice.
Katrina: 上哦我看见我的这个
Katrina: Oh, I see my painting.
Katrina: 这是我的画挂画
Katrina: This is my painting.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Katrina: 好好好又找不到我的
Katrina: Alright, can't find mine again.
Jake:什么刀啊
Jake: What knife?
Katrina: 剪刀
Katrina: Scissors.
Jake:我们刚刚也没用
Jake: We didn't use it just now.
Jake:呵呵我给你开了
Jake: Haha, I opened it for you.
Alice:眼镜还没好吗
Alice: Are the glasses not ready yet?
Jake:你眼镜确实没好哎
Jake: Your glasses aren't ready.
Jake:我靠你眼镜好了
Jake: Oh, your glasses are ready now.
Katrina: 那你下班了睡觉去吧
Katrina: Then go to sleep after work.
Katrina: i found a girl
Katrina: I found a girl.
Katrina: beautiful and sweet
Katrina: Beautiful and sweet.
Katrina: 10点上班
Katrina: Work starts at 10.
Alice:上钟
Alice: Time to clock in.
Katrina: 最开始洗头
Katrina: First, wash your hair.
Jake:能能能能能
Jake: Can, can, can, can.
Jake:很能特别能
Jake: Very capable, extremely capable.
Jake:我们直接上去吧
Jake: Let's go up directly.
Jake:直接上去吧
Jake:你你你这个确实没打好
Jake: You really didn't do this well.
Katrina: 我可以戴久一点
Katrina: I can wear it for longer.
Katrina: 因为我有很多事要干
Katrina: Because I have a lot to do.
Alice:倒还是不倒戴还是不戴呢
Alice: Should I wear it or not?
Alice:带还是不带
Alice: Wear it or not?
Jake:呃你你这个嗯嗯呵
Jake: Uh, you, you, this, mm, haha.
Jake:呵你这个就断了
Jake: Haha, this just broke.
Jake:你这你这你这个电
Jake: Your, your, your electricity.
Jake:你这眼镜他可喜欢断
Jake: Your glasses tend to break.
Katrina: （歌词）i found a girl beautiful and sweet
Katrina: (Lyrics) I found a girl, beautiful and sweet.
Katrina: （歌词） 啦啦啦
Katrina: (Lyrics) La la la.
Katrina: 真是一个温馨的房间耶
Katrina: This is such a cozy room.
Katrina: 是像变态一样
Katrina: It's like a pervert.
其他人：像变态一样
Others: Like a pervert.
其他人：刚刚才新上了一窝
Others: Just recently had a litter.
Katrina: 真的吗我看一下我有放什么东西
Katrina: Really? Let me check what I put here.
Katrina: 挺好的呀
Katrina: It's pretty good.
Katrina: 我觉得房间很温馨
Katrina: I think the room is very cozy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
其他人：房间乱了也没关系
Others: It doesn't matter if the room is messy.
Shure: 有关系
Shure: It matters.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
其他人：没有
Others: No, it doesn't.
其他人：  但是我女朋友的房间
Others: But my girlfriend's room...
其他人：钻的简直是太离谱了
Others: ...is ridiculously messy.
Katrina: 只是说在一些大的事件上
Katrina: Just saying for big events...
Katrina: 要提前做好规划
Katrina: ...we need to plan ahead.
Katrina: 而这个东西为啥要去花时间收拾
Katrina: And why spend time tidying up this stuff?
Katrina: 他反而马上滚蛋
Katrina: He should just get out.
Katrina: 不整齐从小到大没有整齐过
Katrina: Never been tidy since I was little.
Katrina: 我妈说我像个狗窝
Katrina: My mom says my room looks like a dog's den.
Katrina: 我是那种一年心情好一次全部整理
Katrina: I only clean up once a year when I'm in a good mood.
其他人：我也是
Others: Me too.
Katrina: 那你这心情不好排解的方法还挺健康
Katrina: Well, your way of dealing with bad moods is quite healthy.
Katrina: 哎我是不没没开啊
Katrina: Hey, did I turn it on?
Katrina: 我亮了吗哦亮了
Katrina: Am I lit up? Oh, I am.
Katrina: 放歌了
Katrina: Playing music now.
Katrina: 感觉少点music少点灵魂
Katrina: Feels like it lacks music, lacks soul.
其他人：我放
Others: I'll play some.
Katrina: 这在哪买的来着我找找
Katrina: Where did I buy this from? Let me check.
Jake:太尼玛慢了
Jake: Too damn slow.
Alice:上钟
Alice: On the clock.
Katrina: 上妆噔噔噔
Katrina: Putting on makeup, dun dun dun.
Jake:吼
Jake: Whoa.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:这是宇轩的
Jake: This is Yuxuan's.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:我我给他拆拆一下
Jake: I'll take it apart for him.
Katrina: 没什么不能看的呀
Katrina: There's nothing that can't be seen.
Katrina: 大家都是成年人
Katrina: We're all adults here.
其他人：都是成年人
Others: We're all adults here.
Shure: 你刚喝一口
Shure: You just took a sip.
其他人：可以那天晚上喝多了
Others: Maybe you drank too much that night.
其他人：那个主页挺好
Others: That homepage was pretty good.
Katrina: 啊我什么时候说过什么话吗
Katrina: Ah, did I say something?
Katrina: 没说什么乱七八糟的话吧
Katrina: I didn't say anything crazy, did I?
其他人：她咋滴了
Others: What happened to her?
Katrina: 我怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong with me?
Katrina: 火锅那回吗
Katrina: Was it during the hot pot night?
Katrina: 那天你们都没套出我本优男的话了
Katrina: You guys didn't get me to spill any secrets that day.
Katrina: 说明我还行
Katrina: So I did pretty well.
其他人：主要那天我哥也喝多了
Others: Mainly, my brother also drank too much that day.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 你们喝的真的太慢了我只能一个人喝
Shure: You guys drink too slowly, I have to drink alone.
Jake:啊你这就讨论了
Jake: Ah, are you discussing now?
Jake:云服务器
Jake: Cloud server.
Jake:讨论讨论iOS系统传
Jake: Discuss, discuss the iOS system transmission.
Katrina: 这谁呀
Katrina: Who is this?
Shure: 对这个你能解决吗就是
Shure: Can you solve this?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:请请请说
Jake: Please, please, go on.
Shure:  就是那个他那个
Shure: It's just that, um...
Shure: 就是开唱调动不了你的眼镜
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Ah, no.
Jake:他还没唱完呢
Jake: He hasn't finished singing.
Jake:他还有几分钟
Jake: He still has a few minutes.
Shure: 他那个调动不了麦克风
Shure: It can't activate the microphone.
Jake:拍唱
Jake: Snap sing.
Jake:第二步
Jake: Step two.
Shure: 就是mac版本拍唱调用不了麦克风
Shure: The Mac version of Snap Sing can't activate the microphone.
Jake:你别用你不用拍唱
Jake: Don't use it, don't use Snap Sing.
Jake:跑你们两行跑呗行吗
Jake: Just run your two lines, okay?
Jake:开唱里边有命令行
Jake: There's a command line in Snap Sing.
Jake:你用同样的命令去跑他
Jake: Use the same command to run it.
Shure: 东西是就是UI界面上拿UI做的
Shure: The thing is, it's done with the UI interface.
Jake:那你可以命令行调出来
Jake: But you can call it from the command line.
Shure: 啊也可以
Shure: Ah, that works too.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 然后这样的话就OK了
Shure: Then it should be okay.
Jake:对对
Jake: Right, right.
Jake:你就跳过拍唱他的这个傻逼东西
Jake: Just skip over recording this dumb stuff of his.
Shure: 明白了
Shure: Got it.
Jake:好这答辩了这呵呵呵
Jake: Okay, this defense is done, haha.
Shure: 解决了哦对
Shure: Solved, oh yeah.
Shure: 我当时好像确实是这么弄的
Shure: I think that's exactly how I did it.
Shure: OK感谢杨老板
Shure: OK, thanks, Jake.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
其他人：一会回去给你刷支穿云箭
Others: We'll send you a sky rocket later.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: how can i help you
Shure: How can I help you?
Shure: today so today
Shure: Today, so today.
Shure: we will talk about
Shure: We will talk about.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:perfect
Jake: Perfect.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:也能够圣旨上来
Jake: Can you bring the decree up?
Shure: 我们用中文的
Shure: Let's use Chinese.
Shure: 还是中文的啊
Shure: Let's keep it in Chinese, huh?
Jake:啊你想咋样咋样呗
Jake: Ah, however you want.
其他人：中文吧
Others: Let's use Chinese.
Jake:中文吧中文可以啊
Jake: Chinese is fine, yeah.
Jake:就中文吧
Jake: Let's stick with Chinese.
Shure:  帮我想一些
Shure: Help me think of some...
Katrina: 我靠这玩意不是有甲醛吗
Katrina: Oh my god, doesn't this stuff have formaldehyde?
Jake:啊你
Jake: Ah, you...
Jake:哦我靠
Jake: Oh my god...
Shure:   世界地球日
Shure: Earth Day.
Katrina: 你不是主办方吗你
Katrina: Aren't you the organizer?
Shure:   的知识问答
Shure: The knowledge quiz.
Katrina: 哎都是哦送了挂
Katrina: Ah, they all passed easily.
Jake:哇第一个好问题
Jake: Wow, that's a good question.
Katrina: 哎那这是填空题的话
Katrina: Ah, if it's a fill-in-the-blank question...
Katrina: 这也太难了吧
Katrina: That's too hard, isn't it?
Katrina: 这能不能做人选择题
Katrina: Can we make it a multiple-choice question?
Jake:1970是对的
Jake: 1970 is correct.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Alright.
Jake:特意查的
Jake: Specifically checked it.
Jake:但是但是但是
Jake: But, but, but...
Jake:前几天那个那什么11132132是可以出一下
Jake: The other day, the thing 11132132 can be used.
Katrina: 其实我的主题是小王子
Katrina: Actually, my theme is The Little Prince.
Katrina: 我那个我那个小
Katrina: I, I, um...
Jake:对哈哈哈哈
Jake: Right, hahaha.
Katrina: 就是小狐狸嘛
Katrina: It's the little fox, you know?
Katrina: 小狐狸
Katrina: The little fox.
Katrina: 给他配个星星的那个围巾也是小王子
Katrina: And I gave him a star scarf, also from The Little Prince.
Jake:请解释132为什么是回文数
Jake: Please explain why 132 is a palindrome.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 动物世界加小王子
Katrina: Animal World plus The Little Prince.
Lucia:嘉宾会以为他们来到了28吧
Lucia: The guests might think they've come to room 28.
Jake:哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Katrina: 天使一直在
Katrina: The angel is always there.
Lucia:我眼睛有点散光
Lucia: My eyes are a bit astigmatic.
Jake:卧槽本来就不清楚
Jake: Damn, it was blurry to begin with.
Jake:跟你眼睛没关系
Jake: It's not your eyes.
Jake:哈哈哈我到这我到这我都看不清
Jake: Hahaha, even when I get here, I can't see it clearly.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:我以为我眼睛有点散光
Lucia: I thought it was my eyes being astigmatic.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你要能看清你这眼睛不是闪光
Jake: If you could see it clearly, it wouldn't be astigmatic.
Jake:你这哈哈哈你对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Jake:哈哈你要能看清你多少就是有点冲鼻
Jake: Hahaha, if you could see it clearly, it would be a bit suspicious.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:我要能看清它多少有点不正常了
Lucia: If I could see it clearly, it would be a bit abnormal.
Lucia:对对对不过我眼睛是真有点散光
Lucia: Right, right, but my eyes are really a bit astigmatic.
Lucia:我以为是因为我的原因
Lucia: I thought it was my fault.
Lucia:没想到大家都看不清
Lucia: Didn't expect everyone to see it blurry.
Lucia:那我就放心了
Lucia: Now I'm relieved.
Lucia:啊哈
Lucia: Aha.
Jake:世界地球日创始人盖洛德
Jake: Earth Day founder Gaylord.
Shure: 艾伯特爱因斯坦
Shure: Albert Einstein.
Jake:哈哈哈爱因斯坦
Jake: Hahaha, Einstein.
Katrina: 他是男的
Katrina: He's a man.
Jake:哈哈哈常年活动放烟花
Jake: Hahaha, always setting off fireworks.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 全球最大的环境运动是什么世界
Shure: What's the biggest environmental movement in the world?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈泼水节吧要不
Jake: Hahahaha, maybe the Water Splashing Festival?
Lucia: 为什么选择4月22日座的世界地球日你看那个B
Lucia: Why choose April 22 as Earth Day, look at that B...
Shure: 哈哈哈不知道不知道
Shure: Hahaha, I don't know, I don't know.
Shure: 这个c
Shure: This C...
Shure: 这个c应该改成TV是世界第几位
Shure: This "c" should be changed to "TV", ranking in the world.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia:国庆劳动节
Lucia: National Day Labor Day.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia:感觉一个节日不够
Lucia: Feels like one holiday isn't enough.
Lucia:是吧要喜上加喜哈哈
Lucia: Right, gotta double the happiness, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈他不会哈
Jake: Hahaha, he won't, ha.
Shure: 重新修正你的问题与答案
Shure: Correct your question and answer.
Jake:哈哈他他会说自己不会联网
Jake: Haha, he says he can't connect to the internet.
Shure: 什么东西我在这放什么呢
Shure: What is this, what am I putting here?
Jake:哦他连网英英文的是吧
Jake: Oh, he connects to the English internet, right?
Shure: 让我们看不出来是吧
Shure: Makes it hard for us to understand, right?
Shure: 欺负我们他妈是中国人
Shure: Bullying us because we're Chinese.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure: 是吧啊哦
Shure: Right, ah, oh.
Jake:哦还有每每年还有
Jake: Oh, and every year there is...
Jake:这个是地球日的主题
Jake: This is the theme for Earth Day.
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: So interesting.
Jake:可以你说前面几条都挺好
Jake: Okay, what you said earlier was pretty good.
Jake:前面那几个弱智
Jake: Those earlier ones were dumb.
Jake:8的题目我觉得挺好的
Jake: I think the question about 8 was pretty good.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:70%的海洋和30%的陆地也加上了
Jake:可以呵呵
Jake: Okay, hehe.
Jake:可以啊这个东西要抢答
Jake: Okay, this one needs to be answered quickly.
Jake:这个呵呵呵
Jake: This, hehe.
Lucia:有70%的海洋和百分之三十的陆地
Lucia: There's 70% ocean and 30% land.
Lucia:剩下30%的海洋 还有70%陆地去哪
Lucia: So where did the remaining 30% ocean and 70% land go?
Jake:了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:这玩意都在抢答
Jake: Everyone's rushing to answer.
Jake:都要抢答了
Jake: All rushing to answer.
Lucia:还有陨石
Lucia: And meteors.
Lucia:为什么看陨石坑里
Lucia: Why look at meteor craters?
Lucia:哈哈哈是跟地球有关
Lucia: Haha, it's related to Earth.
Jake:好嘞哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahaha.
Jake:挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good, pretty good.
Shure: what major
Shure: What major
Shure: government agency was formally retracted in the first person
Shure: Government agency was formally retracted in the first person
Shure: the usc
Shure: The USC
Jake:你们的朋友英文好吗呵
Jake: Is your friend's English good?
Shure: 我的朋友
Shure: My friend
Shure: 我的朋友也是国际学生
Shure: My friend is also an international student
Jake:呵行可以
Jake: Oh, okay, that's fine
其他人：那还是换成中文吧
Others: Let's just switch to Chinese then
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Shure: 7个够吗不够吧
Shure: Are 7 enough? Probably not, right?
Lucia: 10个吧
Lucia: Let's make it 10
Jake:10个吧凑够10个
Jake: Yeah, let's make it 10
其他人:什么 7030
Others: What? 7030?
Jake:哈哈用
Jake: Haha, use it
Jake:用啊用啊用啊用啊
Jake: Use it, use it, use it, use it
Jake:用啊 7030啊
Jake: Use it, 7030
Jake:然后那什么爱因斯坦那个用啊
Jake: And then, use that Einstein one too
Jake:啊对啊
Jake: Ah, right
Jake:这改掉对
Jake: Yeah, change this
Jake:啊 90啊啊啊
Jake: Ah, 90, ah, ah, ah
Jake:fresh OK
Jake: Fresh, okay
Jake:knocked in的OK OK
Jake: Knocked in, okay, okay
Jake:那8分19秒是什么东西
Jake: So, what's that 8 minutes 19 seconds thing?
Jake:我靠为什么
Jake: Why the heck
Jake:这三打一场吗
Jake: Is this a three-player game?
Jake:这不是哦
Jake: Isn't it?
Tasha: 啊太阳灯光闪到地球
Tasha: Ah, the sunlight flashes onto the Earth
Shure: 啊这个确实
Shure: Ah, indeed
Shure: 这个高中还还
Shure: This high school still, still
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 咋还不给我发教程
Katrina: Why haven't you sent me the tutorial yet?
Jake:星球对抗塑料
Jake: Planets fighting plastic
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
Jake:今年的主题星球大战塑料
Jake: This year's theme is Star Wars against plastic
Katrina: Shure:
Katrina: Shure
Shure: 我看成Tom然后found worse worse stormy呵呵呵
Shure: I read it as Tom and then found worse, worse stormy, haha
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:太平洋垃圾袋
Jake: Pacific garbage patch
Katrina: 哎呦这好正经啊
Katrina: Oh, this is serious
Katrina: 这你看联网就是不一样
Katrina: See, the internet does make a difference
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 路线你那些水母灯什么做好了吗
Katrina: Have you finished those jellyfish lamps and other things?
Katrina: 咱明天能
Katrina: Can we...
Lucia:我觉得来不及
Lucia: I don't think we'll make it in time.
Lucia:哈哈我为啥要明天才能到
Lucia: Haha, why does it have to be done by tomorrow?
Katrina: 那咋整展位都没东西
Katrina: What should we do if the booth has nothing?
Katrina: 我明天早上
Katrina: Tomorrow morning...
Katrina: 明天早上是不是得稍微早点起啊
Katrina: Should we get up a bit earlier tomorrow morning?
Katrina: 如果要做甜品啊
Katrina: If we need to make desserts...
Katrina: 我们就没东西
Katrina: We won't have anything.
Jake:对对对对可以明天几点
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah. What time tomorrow?
Alice:明天几点上钟
Alice: What time do we start tomorrow?
Katrina: 有事我肯定能早点起哦
Katrina: If there's something, I can definitely get up early.
Lucia:我觉得
Lucia: I think...
Katrina: 别小瞧我
Katrina: Don't underestimate me.
Lucia:我觉得水母可能就像那个纸箱狗一样
Lucia: I think the jellyfish might be like that cardboard dog.
Lucia: 就算我们能做这些能写最多能做俩
Lucia: Even if we can make them, we can only make two at most.
其他人:你们那个小狗准备做多少
Others: How many of those little dogs are you planning to make?
Lucia:本来打算一个人做一个的
Lucia: We originally planned for each person to make one.
Lucia: 但是大家我们太忙了
Lucia: But we've been too busy.
Katrina: 那我们那个大家的展板能有什么
Katrina: So, what can we put on everyone's display board?
Katrina: 你你准备啥啊
Katrina: What are you preparing?
Katrina: 你准备的是啥
Alice:我准备啥
Alice: What am I preparing?
Katrina: 就是明天如果我们没我们要展示的话
Katrina: If we don't have anything to show tomorrow...
Alice:小狗吧
Alice: The little dog, I guess.
Jake:卖狗
Jake: Selling dogs.
Katrina: 刚开始的时候
Katrina: At the beginning...
Katrina: 大家不都准备了一个idea吗
Katrina: Didn't everyone come up with an idea?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Alice:水晶球忘拿了
Alice: Forgot to bring the crystal ball.
Katrina: 呵好气死在了第一步
Katrina: Haha, so frustrating, right from the start.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia:没事到我们还可以玩
Lucia: It's okay, we can still have fun.
Katrina: 我靠真的有够劈的
Katrina: Oh my god, this is so messed up.
Jake:啊啥啥玩意啊
Jake: Ah, what's this?
Jake:这啥玩意
Jake: What is this?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：学校是做啥玩意
Others: What's the school making?
Jake:起啥玩意
Jake: What's this for?
Jake:这太弱智了
Jake: This is so stupid.
Jake:这这弱智
Jake: This, this is stupid.
Jake:真是我智
Jake: Really, I'm dumb.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:我们
Jake: We...
Lucia:他竟然让我对人不痴对未来很失败
Lucia: He actually made me feel like a failure towards people and the future.
Jake:哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Jake:所以我们卖狗是吧
Jake: So we're selling dogs, right?
Jake:对水线球
Jake: For the baseline ball.
Alice: 我把狗卖了吧
Alice: Should I just sell the dog?
Jake:好水线球
Jake: Sure, baseline ball.
Alice:没忘买了
Alice: Didn't forget to buy it.
Katrina: 狗狗一共就两个是吧
Katrina: We only have two dogs, right?
Jake:买忘哦哦哦忘忘买了
Jake: Forgot to buy, oh oh oh, forgot.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: Don't know.
Lucia: 我压的那个花压好了然后还没拆
Lucia: The flower I pressed is ready, but I haven't unpacked it.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Right.
Alice:我的狗跟我的花能拆开卖哈哈哈
Alice: Can I sell my dog and my flower separately? Hahaha.
其他人：那个这样有点问题
Others: That might be a problem.
Alice:啊好嘞
Alice: Ah, okay.
其他人：他显示有一个文件
Others: It shows there's a file.
Jake:呃replace吧
Jake: Uh, replace it.
Jake:嗯行
Jake: Mm, okay.
Shure: 不会又是我的吧
Shure: It's not mine again, is it?
Jake:就是你的
Jake: It's yours.
Tasha: 你猜猜看
Tasha: Guess who?
Tasha: 咱们三维一个没有眼
Tasha: We three don't have a...
Tasha: 镜的人是谁吧
Tasha: ...mirror, who is it?
Shure: 不猜猜看
Shure: Not guessing.
Shure: ：现在是你
Shure: It's you now.
Alice:好难猜啊
Alice: So hard to guess.
Shure:  原来是你
Shure: It was you.
Katrina: 帮我拿下real行吗
Katrina: Can you help me with the real one?
Shure:  不行
Shure: No.
Katrina: 行吗求你了
Katrina: Please, can you?
Katrina: 谢谢你感恩
Katrina: Thank you, much appreciated.
Katrina: 这东西怎么做啊谢谢
Katrina: How do you do this? Thank you.
Katrina: 好喝这桃子味真好喝
Katrina: This tastes so good, this peach flavor is amazing.
Katrina: 老铁
Katrina: Buddy.
Katrina: 我决定自己按照自己的想法做
Katrina: I've decided to do things my own way.
Jake:我们的甜品一个卖多少钱
Jake: How much are we selling our desserts for?
Jake:拍卖是吧
Jake: Auction, right?
Katrina: 那主要就是
Katrina: Well, mainly...
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 我们甜品还是不要拍卖了甜品固定价格
Shure: Let's not auction the desserts. Let's fix the price.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 主要让大家循环手中的20币
Shure: The main thing is to keep the 20 coins circulating among everyone.
Jake:好行行对
Jake: Okay, sure, right.
Jake:要保证货币稳定流通
Jake: We need to ensure the currency circulates steadily.
Jake:那您卖什么呀啊
Jake: So, what are you going to sell?
Jake:您卖什么呀您
Jake: What are you going to sell?
Jake:您卖艺吧
Jake: How about you perform?
Jake:要不呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Otherwise... hahahahaha.
Katrina: 点歌
Katrina: Song requests.
Jake:唉呀妈呀
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:你卖什么呀
Jake: What are you going to sell?
Jake:卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 给他少少那么点工作
Katrina: Give him just a little bit of work.
Jake:多多少个币
Jake: How many coins?
Jake:哈哈多少个币
Jake: Hahaha, how many coins?
Jake:多少个币
Jake: How many coins?
Jake:就卖艺呗你就
Jake: Just perform, you.
Katrina: 来给我架个钢管
Katrina: Set up a pole for me.
Lucia: 不是咱们这数学是全年龄项目吧
Lucia: Isn't this math thing supposed to be for all ages?
Shure: 那最起码得会装环境
Shure: At the very least, you need to know how to set up the environment.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:所以已经排除了一部分人了哎
Lucia: So, we've already excluded some people, huh?
Jake:露西亚你这个灯我看一下
Jake: Lucia, let me check your light.
Jake:哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:雨轩你卖什么呀
Jake: Yuxuan, what are you going to sell?
Katrina: 我那个压花的东西明天早上做
Katrina: I'll make those pressed flowers tomorrow morning.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 或者我今天晚上也做
Katrina: Or I'll do them tonight.
Jake:就是卖花
Jake: So, you're selling flowers.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:卖
Jake: Sell
Jake:题就是这些题了是吧
Jake: So these are the questions, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah
Jake:地球的南极冰盖
Jake: How much fresh water is locked in the Earth's Antarctic ice sheet?
Jake:锁定了百分之多少淡水
Jake: What percentage?
Jake:给个分
Jake: Give a score
Jake:你让他给个分吧
Jake: Ask him to give a score
Jake:你让他给个难度分吧
Jake: Ask him to give a difficulty score
Jake:粘贴
Jake: Paste
Tasha: 这什么东西
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 只有蛋白
Tasha: Only egg whites
Tasha: 剩的蛋白没用没用了
Tasha: The leftover egg whites are useless
Shure: 咱们发币的这个问卷准备几个
Shure: How many of these questionnaires are we preparing?
Lucia:好问题
Lucia: Good question
Shure: 一个题 给多少啊总共10个题那不能给10
Shure: How much for one question? There are 10 questions in total, so can't give 10
Jake:一个两个呗
Jake: One or two
Jake:一或2
Jake:一份两份
Jake: One or two
Jake:一份两份行不
Jake: One or two sets, okay?
Jake:就两种
Jake: Just two types
Shure:  2-4分吧
Shure: 2-4 points maybe
Jake:啊这么多
Jake: Oh, that much
Jake:行可以
Jake: Okay, fine
Katrina: 唉
Katrina: Hey
Katrina: 又没剪到了
Katrina: Missed it again
Jake:7-4分吧一给一个那个沙雕的
Jake: 7-4 points, give one of those silly ones
Jake:比方说爱因斯坦还是牛顿还是那个谁
Jake: Like Einstein, or Newton, or who else
Jake:什么尼亚森还是还是修硕
Jake: Someone like Niasen or Shure
Katrina: 剪刀你们知道在啊
Katrina: Do you know where the scissors are?
Katrina: 你手上有剪刀
Katrina: You have scissors
Katrina: 那把红剪刀呢
Katrina: Where are the red scissors?
Lucia:对有一个
Lucia: Yeah, there's one
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Lucia:是的那把红剪刀好用一点
Lucia: Yes, the red scissors are better
Katrina: 那把充电宝好用一点
Katrina: The power bank is better
Katrina: 但我也没找
Katrina: But I couldn't find it
Lucia:但我也没找见
Lucia: But I couldn't find it
Katrina: 剪刀
Katrina: Scissors
Katrina: 你有看见剪刀吗
Katrina: Did you see the scissors?
其他人：剪刀
Others: Scissors
Katrina: 感觉每天在找
Katrina: Feels like I'm always looking for them
Katrina: 剪刀剪刀剪刀剪刀剪刀
Katrina: Scissors, scissors, scissors, scissors, scissors
其他人：刘帅呢
Others: Where's Choiszt?
Katrina: 打火机我先征用了
Katrina: I'm commandeering the lighter
Katrina: 偷偷走吧
Katrina: Let's sneak out
Katrina: 你们两个
Katrina: You two
其他人：居然还要打台球
Others: Seriously, you want to play pool now?
其他人：现在就打
Others: Let's play now
Katrina: 你们打台球
Katrina: You guys are playing pool
Katrina: 我一会就回去
Katrina: I'll be back soon
Katrina: 不是反正都还没做完呢
Katrina: Not like we've finished everything yet
其他人：不一定还有啥事
Others: Who knows what else there is
其他人：还要导导数据
Others: We still need to import the data
其他人：刘帅见你明天唱一首普通朋友
Others: Choiszt, see you tomorrow, sing "Ordinary Friends"
Katrina: 唱吧
Katrina: Go ahead, sing
其他人：普通朋友 呀
Others: "Ordinary Friends", yeah
Katrina: 在做
Katrina: Working on it
其他人：这个把这个机催下来了
Others: This has pushed the machine down
其他人：给你给你和个 音
Others: Here, here, harmonize with this note
Katrina: 普通朋友前奏不是很难弹吗
Katrina: Isn't the intro to "Ordinary Friends" pretty hard to play?
其他人：你也弹吉他吧
Others: Do you play guitar too?
Katrina: 学过一点点
Katrina: I learned a little bit.
Katrina: 但后来按不了
Katrina: But then I couldn't keep up.
其他人：为什么手小吗
Others: Why? Are your hands small?
Katrina: 我我按不紧
Katrina: I couldn't press hard enough.
其他人：那就得练
Others: You need to practice more.
Katrina: 没坚持下来
Katrina: I didn't stick with it.
其他人：菜就多练
Others: If you're bad, just practice more.
其他人：我操你他妈喝了一点就好红
Others: Damn, you get so red after just a little drink.
Katrina: 我又红了吗
Katrina: Am I red again?
其他人：他太搞笑了
Others: He's so funny.
Katrina: 我靠我喝的是real
Katrina: Damn, I'm drinking for real.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这说一句太丢人了
Katrina: Haha, saying that is so embarrassing.
Katrina: 找剪刀啊
Katrina: Looking for scissors?
Katrina: 那个红色昨天就没了吗
Katrina: Wasn't that red one gone yesterday?
Katrina: 我在
Katrina: I'm here.
其他人：（歌词）现在就想要说明白
Others: (Lyrics) Now I just want to make it clear.
其他人：（歌词）觉得自己好失败
Others: (Lyrics) I feel like such a failure.
其他人：（歌词）当深渊如果重来
Others: (Lyrics) If the abyss could start over.
其他人：（歌词）我愿意改变
Others: (Lyrics) I am willing to change
其他人：（歌词）重新再来一遍
Others: (Lyrics) Start all over again
Katrina: （歌词）我无法只是普通朋友
Katrina: (Lyrics) I can't just be a normal friend
Katrina: （歌词）叫我怎么能放手
Katrina: (Lyrics) How can I let go
Katrina: （歌词）你说爱
Katrina: (Lyrics) You say love
Katrina: （歌词）i only wanna be your friend
Katrina: (Lyrics) I only wanna be your friend
Katrina: 明天你上台表演吧
Katrina: You should perform on stage tomorrow
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No
其他人：（歌词）耶你心中只是角色范
Others: (Lyrics) Yeah, you are just a character
其他人：（歌词）不是情人
Others: (Lyrics) Not a lover
其他人：（歌词）我感激你对我这样的坦白
Others: (Lyrics) I appreciate your honesty with me
其他人：（歌词）在我给你的爱但是收不回来
Others: (Lyrics) Despite the love I gave you but couldn't take back
Katrina: 你只是beyoufriend
Katrina: You are just be your friend
Katrina: 呀还没有收衣服
Katrina: Oh, I haven't collected the clothes yet
Katrina: 这干了吗
Katrina: Is this dry?
Katrina: 你啥时候洗的呀
Katrina: When did you wash it?
Alice:这是你的吗不是
Alice: Is this yours? No?
Katrina: 哎剪刀
Katrina: Oh, scissors
Katrina: 我看看外面
Katrina: Let me check outside
Katrina: （歌词）看清你的陌生叫我怎么能放手
Katrina: (Lyrics) Seeing your unfamiliarity, how can I let go
Katrina: 太好听了
Katrina: So beautiful
Katrina: （歌词）i only wanna be your friend
Katrina: (Lyrics) I only wanna be your friend
Katrina: （歌词）我在
Katrina: (Lyrics) I am
Katrina: （歌词）你心中只是just a friend
Katrina: (Lyrics) In your heart just a friend
Katrina: （歌词）可是情人我感激你对我这样的坦白
Katrina: (Lyrics) But as a lover, I appreciate your honesty with me
Katrina: （歌词）我给你的爱暂时收
Katrina: (Lyrics) The love I gave you temporarily
Katrina: 是谁看了他的演唱会是我
Katrina: Who watched his concert? It was me
Katrina: 好吧我放弃了
Katrina: Alright, I give up
Katrina: （歌词）哈哈你妈没有告诉你
Katrina: (Lyrics) Haha, your mom didn't tell you
Katrina: （歌词）长到要说对不起
Katrina: (Lyrics) You need to apologize when you grow up
Katrina: （歌词）嗯嗯哼哼
Katrina: (Lyrics) Mm-hmm, hum-hum
Katrina: （歌词） 他到底干啥
Katrina: (Lyrics) What exactly is he doing
Shure: 撞到我了
Shure: He bumped into me
Shure: 快说对不起
Shure: Hurry and apologize
Katrina: 对不起辛巴塞
Katrina: Sorry, Simba
Katrina: 还是没有找到那个剪刀
Katrina: Still couldn't find those scissors
Katrina: 看来是做不成了
Katrina: Looks like it's not happening
Shure: 我们结束了
Shure: We're done
Shure: 问卷那弱智问题要有一些吗
Shure: Should there be some dumb questions on the questionnaire?
Katrina: 没有剪刀
Katrina: No scissors.
Lucia:为什么陨石总能落在陨石坑里
Lucia: Why do meteorites always land in craters?
Katrina: 你剪刀还用吗
Katrina: Do you still need the scissors?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 啊你微信还我一个哎呦妈
Katrina: Oh, you still owe me a WeChat message, oh my god.
Jake:你微信发我一份啊
Jake: Send me a copy on WeChat.
Shure: 这个问卷什么
Shure: What's with this questionnaire?
Jake:对我再加几个弱智问题就行
Jake: Yeah, I'll just add a few more dumb questions.
Lucia:不过那个剪刀不太好用吧
Lucia: But those scissors aren't very good, right?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哎哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:你大概拼一下吧
Jake: Just piece it together.
Jake:这DPQ题
Jake: This DPQ question.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's done.
Shure: 我给你找纸
Shure: I'll find you some paper.
Jake:好妙啊妙啊
Jake: Great, fantastic.
Katrina: 给你张纸
Katrina: Here's some paper.
Jake:什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Jake:草稿纸
Jake: Scrap paper.
Jake:要干啥
Jake: For what?
Katrina: paper
Katrina: Paper.
Jake:paper paper
Jake: Paper, paper.
Katrina: 呵呵呵paper paper
Katrina: Hehehe, paper, paper.
Jake:来一封来一张paper
Jake: Give me a piece of paper.
Katrina: paper
Katrina: Paper.
Katrina: 对你的毕业论文喏
Katrina: For your thesis, you know.
Jake:你的毕业论
Jake: Your thesis.
Shure: 别你的我的的我们的
Shure: Stop saying "yours" and "mine," it's "ours."
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Katrina: 我的还没写出来呢还
Katrina: I haven't even written mine yet.
Katrina: 都不配叫paper
Katrina: It doesn't even deserve to be called a paper.
Shure: 还是木浆呢是吧
Shure: It's still pulp, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:美
Jake: Beautiful.
Jake:他会跳的他明天会跳的他明天会跳的
Jake: He'll dance, he'll dance tomorrow, he'll dance tomorrow.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Jake:气氛到了他明天会跳的
Jake: When the mood is right, he'll dance tomorrow.
Shure: 不会
Shure: No, I won't.
Katrina: 谁啊他跳呗
Katrina: Who? Let him dance then.
Jake:啊他啊他
Jake: Ah, him, ah him
Jake:雨轩也跳
Jake: Yuxuan, you jump too
Jake:你们也跳
Jake: You guys jump too
Jake:你们你们仨跳吧
Jake: You three jump then
Jake:站中间那
Jake: Stand in the middle
Lucia: 那不现在没牌的话我们仨分三哦
Lucia: So now if we don't have cards, the three of us split into three teams?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure
Katrina: 我天啊
Katrina: Oh my god
Jake:你三battle
Jake: You three battle
Jake:我觉得可以哈哈
Jake: I think it works, haha
Lucia: 啊明天本来想穿裙子的
Lucia: Ah, I wanted to wear a dress tomorrow
Lucia: 我还得穿裤子
Lucia: Now I have to wear pants
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 没有在地下先装个瓶歘哈哈哈
Shure: Just put a bottle underground first, haha
Katrina: 天
Katrina: Oh dear
Katrina: 垃圾桶呢
Katrina: Where's the trash can?
Katrina: 每天都在找东西
Katrina: I'm always looking for stuff every day
Shure: 吃了吧
Shure: Just eat it
Jake:找啥了paper啊
Jake: What are you looking for, paper?
Katrina: 垃圾桶垃圾桶
Katrina: Trash can, trash can
Jake:垃圾桶不在
Jake: The trash can isn't here
Katrina: 垃圾桶配paper
Katrina: Trash can goes with paper
Jake:很配paper trash can
Jake: Very fitting, paper, trash can
Shure: i found the love
Shure: I found the love
Katrina: 放歌
Katrina: Play the song
Shure: for me
Shure: For me
Katrina: 我看能不能做个一条呢
Katrina: I'll see if I can make a strip
Shure: 发给杨老板
Shure: Send it to Jake
Katrina: 其他的朋友们呢
Katrina: What about the other friends?
Katrina: 你知道第一天我几点起的吗
Katrina: Do you know what time I got up on the first day?
Katrina: 你不在那天8点
Katrina: You weren't there that day, 8 o'clock
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Impressive
Katrina: 后来就再也没有起来过
Katrina: And then I never got up that early again
Jake:哪一天
Jake: Which day?
Katrina: 今睡迟了的
Katrina: The day I slept in
Katrina: 第二天
Katrina: The second day
Katrina: 我以为我们就是有严格按照时间表
Katrina: I thought we were strictly following the schedule
Katrina: 10点半准时开始
Katrina: Start precisely at 10:30
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Katrina: 呵呵后来知道了以后
Katrina: Haha, but later I realized
Katrina: 我就理所当然的不定闹钟了
Katrina: So I obviously didn’t set an alarm.
Katrina: 等他来敲门呵
Katrina: Just waited for him to knock on the door, haha.
Katrina: 好又要下楼一趟
Katrina: Alright, I have to go downstairs again.
Katrina: 热熔胶
Katrina: Hot glue.
Katrina: 我已
Katrina: I’ve...
Katrina: （歌词）走向流沙
Katrina: (Lyrics) Walking towards quicksand.
Katrina: （歌词）爱情
Katrina: (Lyrics) Love.
Katrina: （歌词）我不挣扎
Katrina: (Lyrics) I won’t struggle.
Katrina: （歌词）就随它去吧我不害怕
Katrina: (Lyrics) Just let it be, I’m not afraid.
Katrina: （歌词）爱情好像流沙
Katrina: (Lyrics) Love is like quicksand.
Katrina: （歌词）心里的牵挂
Katrina: (Lyrics) The longing in my heart.
Katrina: （歌词）不愿放下oh baby让我这样吧
Katrina: (Lyrics) I don’t want to let go, oh baby, let me be this way.
Katrina: 哎呀呀呀呀哎呀
Katrina: Ah ya ya ya ya ah ya.
Katrina: 才分开一秒钟
Katrina: Just separated for a second.
Katrina: 哎你俩
Katrina: Hey, you two.
Katrina: 你就叫他
Katrina: Just call him.
Katrina: 难以想象明天要上台
Katrina: Can’t imagine getting on stage tomorrow.
Katrina: 居然没有排练过一次
Katrina: Haven’t even practiced once.
Katrina: 我居然还没做完这个东西
Katrina: I can’t believe I haven’t finished this yet.
Katrina: 对需要热熔胶
Katrina: Yeah, need the hot glue.
Katrina: 是这么做吗拉丝了
Katrina: Is this how you do it? It’s stringy.
Katrina: 天
Katrina: Oh dear.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 就就就就是
Katrina: Just, just, just...
Katrina: 就是这样粘了以后把它这样粘上去
Katrina: Just stick it like this and then stick it on like that.
Katrina: 然后均匀一点的粘就行
Katrina: And then just stick it evenly.
Katrina: 我感觉我做手工就这类就没天赋
Katrina: I feel like I have no talent for crafts.
Katrina: 包括做饭什么的都不行
Katrina: Including cooking and stuff, I can’t do it.
Katrina: 我他妈开个煤气灶学了几年
Katrina: I took years to learn how to use a gas stove.
Katrina: 又不敢开你知道
Katrina: And I still don’t dare to use it, you know.
Katrina: 没有在你的床上在客厅
Katrina: It’s not on your bed, it’s in the living room.
Katrina: 嗯那个清华的男生在放
Katrina: Hmm, that Tsinghua guy is playing music.
Katrina: 然后刘帅在弹吉他
Katrina: And Choiszt is playing the guitar.
Katrina: 太有品了吧
Katrina: So classy.
Katrina: 喜欢陶喆
Katrina: Likes David Tao.
Katrina: 间接自夸
Katrina: Indirect self-praise.
Katrina: 我喜欢小众乐队
Katrina: I like indie bands.
Katrina: 呵再笑一个试试呢
Katrina: Haha, try laughing again.
Katrina: 就是很小众啊
Katrina: They’re really indie.
Katrina: 我的品味
Katrina: My taste.
Shure: 啊你不纯粹了
Shure: Ah, you're not pure anymore.
Shure: 你赚到米了
Shure: You've made money.
Shure: 你不纯粹了
Shure: You're not pure anymore.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 这才是正确的方式
Katrina: This is the right way.
Katrina: 妈的
Katrina: Damn.
Katrina: 真的感觉有十多年没有做过手工了
Katrina: Really feels like I haven't done any crafts for over ten years.
Lucia: 是不是很像啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look similar?
Katrina: 真的耶好像
Katrina: Yeah, it really does.
Katrina: 但你这个比我的好看一点
Katrina: But yours looks a bit better than mine.
Katrina: 你还会反光啊
Katrina: Yours even reflects light.
Lucia: 对他这个有个镀膜好像
Lucia: Yeah, it's got a coating.
Katrina: 嗯你这个做大概要多久啊
Katrina: Hmm, how long did it take you to make this?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Katrina: 我这也不知道
Katrina: I don't know either.
Katrina: 感谢晚上的加班
Katrina: Thanks for the overtime tonight.
Katrina: 哈哈这就是白天太批的那个
Katrina: Haha, this is because we were too lazy during the day.
Katrina: 这就是不按照日程表的坏处
Katrina: This is the downside of not sticking to the schedule.
Katrina: 白天在干什么
Katrina: What were we doing during the day?
Katrina: 我们今天下午
Katrina: This afternoon...
Shure: 主要在外面唠俩小时嗑
Shure: Mainly chatting outside for two hours.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 主要是刚
Katrina: Mainly just...
Katrina: 下午哦
Katrina: This afternoon, oh.
Katrina: 下午正准备干活呢
Katrina: We were just about to start working in the afternoon.
Katrina: 逛超市去了
Katrina: Then we went to the supermarket.
Katrina: 逛完超市回来以后
Katrina: After we came back from the supermarket...
Shure: 今天那趟超市完全可以
Shure: Today's supermarket trip could've totally...
Katrina: 姐姐姐然后回来以后干啥了
Katrina: Sis, and then what did we do when we got back?
Shure: 不知道摆烂了
Shure: No idea, just slacked off.
Shure: 今天啊取快递取了一个小时
Shure: Today, picking up the package took an hour.
Katrina: 哎呀你看这效率
Katrina: Oh man, look at this efficiency.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 笑死我了
Katrina: You crack me up.
Lucia: 买饭吃饭
Lucia: Bought food, ate.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 明天跟我那朋友展示一下
Katrina: I'll show this to my friend tomorrow.
Shure: 给谁
Shure: To whom?
Katrina: 给我那朋友
Katrina: To my friend.
Shure: 哦给我那朋友你说的好像给你男朋友
Shure: Oh, you said that to your friend like you were giving it to your boyfriend.
Katrina: 男朋友是不存在的
Katrina: Boyfriends don’t exist.
Katrina: （歌词）啦啦啦我的宝贝
Katrina: (Lyrics) La la la, my baby.
Katrina: 关键我今天还得洗头我靠
Katrina: The thing is, I still have to wash my hair today, damn.
Katrina: 但但你今天不行
Katrina: But, but you can’t do it today.
Katrina: 上床不觉可脏了吗
Katrina: Isn’t it dirty to go to bed like this?